well let's talk about what's going on at
home for a minute see if we can clean up
the mess down here we got the story from
the new york post hunter biden's former
business partners cooperated completely
with feds in tax probe the new york post
reports devin archer who was awaiting
sentencing in an unrelated fraud case is
among four people reportedly referenced
in a may 15-19 subpoena first reported
by the post sent to jp morgan chase bank
for records related to any transaction
involving the bank of china the others
include james biden a younger brother of
president joe biden a partial copy of
the subpoena was posted online by the
marco polo usa research group headed by
garrett ziegler who works as a white
house policy analyst under who worked as
a white house policy analyst under
former president trump mr archer was not
aware of the specific subpoena from 2019
which appears directed to a bank his
lawyer matthew schwartz told the post in
an email but mr archer has cooperated
completely with the delaware us
attorney's office investigation from the
moment he became aware of it so they're
looking into transactions involving
china the first thing i want to say is
uh look there may be some connection to
hunter biden but if if you were if you
were asking me do i think anything in in
terms of accountability would happen to
the biden family i would say probably
not
maybe if donald trump gets elected in
2024 but uh peter you seem to be much
more of an expert than i so what do you
think well i don't know you might be
right tim i think if the republicans
take the house and the senate you're
going to get congressional hearings they
some of those committees have subpoena
powers will they impeach joe biden i
think they should well they they marry
me very well i mean one of the things
that that troubled me the most in this
new book you know i did the first hunter
biden china stuff back in 2018 in a book
that i wrote and at that time it was a
story of like corruption and cronyism
and self-dealing and all that
what we did more recently for this book
is we went through the hunter biden
laptop and we went through some of the
emails of one of his business partners
who gave us access to his gmail account
and we wanted to figure out so
the biden's got all these deals in china
that hunter wasn't qualified for um who
actually made it rain right who actually
gave the bidens this money which is like
31 million dollars in deals so we traced
it back and what we found is that there
were four guys that set these deals up
every single one of these guys
has links to the highest levels of
chinese intelligence
so like one guy named chaefeng set him
up for a you know a 20 million dollar
payday
you know chef at the time was business
partners with the vice minister of state
security who's in charge of recruiting
foreign spies for the chinese you know
you can't make this i mean and and every
single case this was so you know
the the biden case no longer is just
cronyism and corruption i mean we have
to entertain the notion that the chinese
targeted the bidens they got the they
got the bidens and that the bidens are
compromised you know it's an
intelligence operation i mean it has all
the markings of it isn't it crazy that
we spent so many years talking about
trump and russia yeah but now we're here
talking about biden and china yeah and
and and here you know unlike the trump
case when the trump stuff when the
dossier first came out okay i fell for
it and i was like hey we gotta look at
this like this looks serious we gotta
investigate it and then you know five or
six
months later you realize this thing is
completely falling apart but there you
had no money right you had this this
anonymous dossier but you had no money
you had no deals you had no you know
links to intelligence with the bidens
you've got money nobody disputes they
got the 31 million dollars and now
you've got the fact that the people that
made these deals happen all have these
intelligence links so
it's completely compromised and i think
that congress needs to hold those
hearings and they need to get the bidens
under subpoena to testify in front of
congress
to explain it but i agree with you the
law enforcement you know i've kind of
given up on the fact that they're going
to hold these these elites uh
accountable there's a different set of
uh law and justice for elites than there
is for ordinary americans and and even
as far as it can go with the
congressional hearing look fauci lied
under oath on numerous occasions and
nothing no accountability no
accountability you're exactly right you
look i think at this point
we look at all the past stories we've
already discussed this the split between
the left and the right
i think it's fair if i were to ask all
of you listening do you think when it
comes to you know say joe rogan or
anybody else that the left would be
willing to compromise and say oh okay
we'll we'll concede this point the
answer is of course not they won't
they'll keep pulling and pulling and
pulling it's only the right and the
liberty side that keeps conceding
in that capacity i think it's fair to
realize there will never be federal law
enforcement accountability for joe biden
and his family no matter how much gets
reported on it or anthony fauci no
matter how much it gets reported in
which case what ends up happening is it
doesn't matter if there's hard evidence
or not the republicans come in and
they'll be like oh we're going to
impeach why it's partisan yeah we we
discussed this with um
there was that the pennsylvania story
about the judges striking down the mail
and voting law i don't know if you heard
that recently yeah and the judge
basically refused
to rule on it during the 2020 election
because they said you waited until after
your guy already lost to file this right
the judge had decided because of party
affiliation he would not rule on the
merits because i assume your side is
just doing this to win if we're at the
point where a judge won't look at the
actual merits and we'll just say well
you're team a on team b so i say you
lose yeah well that's going to be that's
happening in law enforcement at what
point do people just say the system is
clearly broken there's not going to be
an accountability so it's going to be
lawfare effectively if the if the you
know policy law fair whatever if the
republicans win the house and the senate
and they're going to impeach joe biden
for the sake of it but this time will
they be able to muster up enough to
actually get a conviction i'd wager
probably not it'll be the exact same
thing we saw and it's it's basically
just a tit-for-tat until finally the the
tower just crumbles and falls because
you know i don't know how our how our
country can sustain this kind of hyper
partisan polit politic you know
political attacks and conflict you know
yeah no it's i mean it's scary i mean
the scenario laid out is is accurate and
scary and part of it is
there's not a sense i mean you guys
disagree with me obviously if you do
there just is not a sense of
truth with a capital t anymore and so
what do i mean it's like it's you know
in the case that you're talking about
the judge it's not a question of the
merits of of the case or the evidence
it's who's bringing
the facts and the evidence i mean i face
the same thing all the time people say
oh you know these are just right-wing
attacks against the bidens and i'm like
explain to me which of these facts are
right-wing i mean they're all from
chinese corporate documents and hong
kong financial records there's no
right-wing facts and left-wing facts
they're facts and you can debate them
and you can say whether they're accurate
but we've reached this point it's like
this post-truth
element where it doesn't really matter
whether it's true it's who's actually
bringing the evidence and i'm going to
attack the messenger rather than
actually deal with the underlying
evidence it's scary well i i it's it's
it's simple i mean i think jimmy dore is
a really great example the dude's
clearly economically and culturally left
but because he questions the
establishment he's right-wing yeah and
that's that's look you know they call me
right-wing and i'm like well look i'm
centrist so i can understand why they
view me and they'll say these things but
like come on jimmy's basically a
socialist and i don't mean that
disrespectfully i mean i think he calls
himself that and they're starting to
argue that he's like a right-wing
grifter right so clearly left and right
just means whose side it just means team
18b it doesn't even mean left and right
anymore yeah and there's matiabe and and
glenn greenwald are kind of in the same
boat i mean those guys are both
left-wing but because they actually want
to try to get to the truth
um they get hammered well uh truth has a
right-wing bias
that's right
yeah what was that colbert huh yeah yeah
yeah nice try how much of a lie do we
live in right now how much truth can
people handle in what increments when we
start rolling out the truth
man
yeah you're getting philosophical yeah
we're built on the
and if we start moving these cards
around there's a chance the entire
thing's gonna this is one of the
theories that that a friend of mine uh
who's in dc former member of congress
said you know i said you know they won't
have these hearings on
uh you know the origins of covet and he
said well of course i won't and i said
what do you mean of course they won't he
said because if they actually come to
the truth they'd have to do something
about it oh
yeah we um we had tom garrett on he
mentioned that when he was in congress
the republicans would come to him and be
like well don't actually support our
bill because then if we win what do we
have left you know and so there were
very much often stories like that or
stories of republicans being like oh we
can't support that bill they'll call us
racist yeah so it's remarkable how when
you learn how things are going behind
the scenes that
it's all one big joke it's one big game
being played well and this is why i mean
look at the rise you know like you and
joe rogan and some of the other people
out there i mean you obviously have to
be courageous what you're doing but part
of it is too you have a a basis of
financial independence based on the
business that you've developed
and that's key i mean you think about
people that get canceled um you know
people that that you know need to fit
into the establishment as part of their
business model if you don't have that
independence i mean you're screwed and
so you know when you're talking about
truth and how much truth do the average
americans want
you just look at leaders and and they
may know what the truth is uh but they
can't
discuss it and enunciate it because it
could destroy their livelihood they
don't have the independence that you
have in other people well i'll tell you
one thing that really drives a lot of
these like left activist types nuts is
that
here we have no investors no big you
know institutional investors in any way
right and so there's always this
narrative of like oh this person is
funded by the koch brothers or the
mercers
and they they i've still i've seen
activists try to make that claim like he
must be getting funding from them and
it's like right no just regular people
are sick and fed up and have started to
fund conversation that they think you
know works for them for uh you know for
someone like joe rogan he just he i i
don't think he runs any kind of
membership thing he's got ad revenue
right but i'm i'm pretty sure if you
know the spotify thing with rogan
resulted in him getting booted and he
announced like sign up for joe rogan
premium yeah he'd be making a hundred
times ten times as much money than he's
making now right 100 million spotify
deal with 11 million listeners per
episode imagine if he got one percent to
give 10 bucks per month and they fear
that joe could make it 120 20 million
per year yeah just off of that no they
fear they fear that they fear the fact
that you've got subscribers they fear
that there are these other independent
sources of information out there because
they can't get to the nub of it
and they can't eliminate it
and and that's really unfortunately what
the left wants is they want dominance
and here's the interesting question that
i would ask you because i have a theory
on this you know the left wants to shut
down debate
it comes from a position of you know
real cultural strength
but i think it it really shows their
profound intellectual weakness
because if they really believe i mean
think about this they shut down all
these speakers from going on college
campus if they really felt like these
conservative speakers going on college
campus are these crazed you know you
know racists misogynist whatever i mean
i'd say like let them stand up there and
embarrass themselves but they don't want
to speak they don't want them to speak
because they know the power of the ideas
they are they are
fundamentally
lack confidence in their own ideas i
think also on top of that even if you
did hear that person's ideas and reject
them on their merits it wouldn't be good
enough for the left because they don't
want you to reject someone because you
thought for yourself and decided to
reject them they want you to reject
somebody because they told you to yeah
yeah you have to obey that's the point i
get that it's like a lot of people it
seems like a lot of people repeating
what they've been told when you talk
about the left and i see that in
religion sometimes people be like i read
it i was told this is real so this is
real and like that's different than when
you really believe something because
then you can debate it to anybody
yeah no that's exactly right you think
it through i mean to be somebody on the
left you can almost get there by osmosis
these days because the culture is
telling you
all these things if you're gonna be you
know center-right you really have to
think things through that's what's
really fascinating you know uh for the
longest time when all media was
controlled when there were only a few
broadcast towers to consume from there
was very little right wing conversation
happening the establishment just
controlled it all and it was fairly
moderate left leaning and slowly moved
drifting left with the rise of the
internet all of a sudden you ended up
with right-wing spaces areas where
individuals could now start speaking and
communicate and maintain their value
systems and that's been been an
impossibility for the left but with that
internet as well you end up with the
left moving 10 times faster than they
ever did pulling further and further
further to the left spiraling out of
control
but uh aside from that i'll just make
the point about joe rogan you know uh in
talking about what the left believes and
you know what what what james was saying
everybody
it's it's almost pointless to even say
because so many people have made this
point already that none of these people
complaining about joe even watch the
watches watch his show
they have no idea why they're mad right
and that's the scary thing and the
example i like to use is uh
this guy you know posted a meme a tweet
in reference to uh joe rogan and a guy
said in germany we have a saying
if there are 11 people at a table
and one of them is a nazi and the other
10 are talking to him you have 11 nazis
and
i mean that's a psychotic statement
because there's so much nuance there is
he there because it's a it's uh you know
did the nazi go to a meeting to
de-radicalize other 10 people like
former you know people trying to
de-radicalize him right but the
fascinating thing there is that the
point they're making about joe is that
it doesn't matter how many people he has
on that support the narrative if he
brings on one who doesn't it's all bad
and it must be you know just removed or
banned in germany the story i like to
bring up is when there was a journalist
and luke lukertkowski was on the show
for a various amount of time and i was
in florida
he was walking down the street when
someone yelled randomly nazi schweinhund
and pointed at him as other journalists
so other random people who had no idea
who he was started physically attacking
him
another guy we know was a journalist and
someone screamed at him randomly nazi
schweinhund and so guys ran up jumped
him and started punching him in the head
and grabbed his camera from him and it's
like he's just some journalist guy
they they hurt these people luke got
beat up just randomly because someone
pointed and said those words that was
all it took for these these psychopaths
to physically harm other people that is
a cult yeah that that and that is
dangerous and when they all come out and
they're like joe rogan must be banned
and you go why because what did he say i
don't know right they don't care they
just want it done and then i think the
question is if 11 people being at a
table and one of them being a nazi means
that all 11 are nazis is daryl davis a
klansman for going to talk to people in
the kkk and trying to de-radicalize them
do you see what happened when daryl
davis went to our event no are you
familiar with daryl davis no he's a
famous black jazz musician who one day
he said to himself i don't understand
how someone could hate me if they don't
even know me so he went and actually met
with white supremacists and klansmen wow
he went to clan rallies and he actually
talked to him wow and then eventually
these clan guys started giving up the
robes and quitting and being like i
never realized these stories weren't
true right amazing so we had an event in
in in the philly suburbs called uh what
was called ending violence racism and
authoritarianism
and it was like a generally classically
liberal event we had a bunch of people
across the political spectrum who all
agreed like hey these are things we
don't like
antifa showed up threatened to burn the
theater down we were forced to move it
to a smaller venue at a casino with more
security and daryl davis was our keynote
speaker
he got a standing ovation from the crowd
as he explained how his the robes had
been given to him
he he at the after party we still had it
across from the original theater because
the people who ran that a venue were
unwilling they were like we're not going
to back down
and when antifa was outside and the
police were blocking it daryl was like
i'm going to go out and talk to these
guys because you know that's his view
he did it with the client they started
screaming at him nazi and racist and
white supremacist and they would not
listen to a word he said and then he
made a post on facebook that went viral
where he said i cannot believe this
that he he he posted this story how he
said he could walk up to a clan meeting
and they would they would talk to him
and tell them what they believed but
these far left antivetives just yelled
at him and refused to talk at all and he
was shocked by it
so to answer to answer to respond to
your point yes
yeah they very much view him as far
right and nazi and all that stuff in
fact he's been smeared because the
klansmen give him the robes and he keeps
them and he shows everybody look what
they've given up and they're like aha
he's got it that proves oh my gosh
it's
so insane
but how do we live with like
you know when you have a massive cult
like that i mean
look i'll make this point too to these
leftists they they they insult and smear
you know the white christian male
sheamus and i do not believe
there's a lot of things we don't yeah
james is very very religious i'm not but
here we are having conversations we get
along we're good friends how is it that
we all found a way to live together
but these these people are absolutists
and don't accept that you know i mean
yeah yeah i mean
if you look at history the the thing
that sticks out to me most are the
maoists right in the cultural revolution
which was um it was you weren't
discussing anything you weren't asking
people to explain anything they would go
through and the village and if they saw
somebody that had uh reading glasses you
know they'd immediately say well you're
an intellectual you're you're a threat
you know they would throw them in prison
based on symbol things like that if you
had books you know you're a threat to
the state and and it's this this this
inability to even have a conversation uh
to try to understand the other person
and it shows it's really not about a
care about people
it's about this this um you know cultic
belief system you know i get nervous
when i think about mao's revolution and
they all were targeting what they called
rightists yes they were big on getting
weeding out the right and i don't want
to find ourselves in the same position
inadvertently
weeding out the leftists like
making the other out of this idea of a
leftist where because that's exactly
what mao was doing
so i i don't want to divide people in
that sense i understand there's there's
a psychosis going around right now but
you know uh ian i i hear you and i agree
with you but i also want to make the
point that you know i made earlier that
there's there's a hard line
when
the left for the most part is completely
i would say almost
is almost absolute in their belief
structure they don't listen to joe
rogan's podcast but they want him purged
they they they go around and destroy and
smash up businesses and burn down
buildings and as long as you know
someone like you is constantly saying
like oh we shouldn't demonize these
people and we should figure out a way to
like you know avoid that conflict
they're going to say thank you for
conceding and giving us more power we'll
exploit you for that maybe it could be
punish the behavior but not the people
well and i would also say too i mean to
tim's point you have this hardcore
element that does this and then you have
what used to be called fellow travelers
right these are the guys that kind of
went along and they're not as strongly
committed and maybe those are the ones
you're talking about the big question
though is tim i don't know what you
think about this is you know what
portion of the of the left are hardcore
left and what portion are followers i
mean can any of them be be persuaded
uh i i do think if we look at the
polling data we mentioned i mentioned
this earlier yeah we're seeing an
erosion from we're seeing a larger
portion of democrat aligned individuals
becoming republican as opposed to the
opposite right that
it shows the democratic party is eroding
i don't think the republican party is
the solution i do think the people that
are joining the republicans are doing
out of frustration and looking for some
kind of meaningful opposition they're
not going to find but you know
i think that's the difference
the people who are in the democratic
alignment are probably default liberal
followers or willfully ignorant and
willfully going along with it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you